votre avis cette photo c'est quoi c'est
un poisson transgénique qui a été créé
pour détecter les polluants et le
poisson vous avez sous les yeux a été
exposé à une substance active qui entre
dans la composition des pilules
contraceptives et sa sexualité on a été
modifié alors est ce que vous saviez que
les oestrogènes des pilules que l'on
retrouve dans les urines vont dans les
égouts les égouts dans les rivières et
tout ça se retrouve en mer et sa paire
tubes très probablement la sexualité des
poissons deuxième exemple les crèmes
bond les crèmes bronzantes vous savez
tous que quand on va à la plage
il faut se badigeonner de crème
bronzante pour se protéger la peau des
brûlures du soleil
alors ces deux exemples qu'est ce qu'il
nous montre
et bien tout simplement que les
connaissances scientifiques évolué qui
aurait pu devancer il ya cinquante ans
que les les oestrogènes des pilules
contraceptives aurait très probablement
une influence sur le comportement sexuel
des poissons qui aurait pu penser que
les crèmes bronzantes aurait très
probablement une influence sur la
mortalité des cons donc c'est la
première idée c'est que la réalité
scientifique évolué avec les
connaissances que l'on en arles
prenons l'exemple du climat du
réchauffement climatique le climat pour
compte
pour le comprendre il faut prendre en
compte plusieurs paramètres de nature
très différente
la composition des gaz dans l'atmosphère
les
le régime des vents des vagues la
formation des nuages des glaces
l'interaction biologique à terre comme
en mer
donc le climat résulte d'une interaction
de d'interactions de toutes sortes entre
l'atmosphère
l'océan est également le vivant les
facteurs à l'origine du réchauffement
climatique sont donc multiples et très
complexe il résulte d'interaction qui
avec un effet domino qu'on n'aurait
jamais pu imaginer il ya encore quelques
années
d'où la deuxième idée c'est que
l'environnement comme tout ce qui est
complexe et très difficile à comprendre
et on ne peut pas le regarder avec un
seul bout de la lorgnette
il faut croiser les regards pour en
comprendre toute la réalité
alors maintenant allons plus loin
la photo qui est derrière moi c'est un
ciel bleu
vous voyez bien regardez bien la photo
c'est acl bleu le ciel bleu d'hawaï en
plein milieu du pacifique
photo de mettons 2006 de 1958
maintenant regardez bien cette autre
photo c'est encore le ciel bleu d'hawaï
en plein milieu du pacifique en 2018
donc en apparence il n'y a aucune
différence les deux yeux sont les mêmes
exactement les mêmes et bien non ce ne
sont pas les mêmes cieux imaginez une
seconde que l'on puisse coloré le gaz
carbonique en verre par exemple et bien
à ce moment là voilà l'image que vous
auriez dû ciel hawaï en 2018
voilà bah tout simplement s'élevèrent
parce que entre 1958
et 2018 la quantité la concentration de
gaz carbonique dans l'atmosphère a
augmenté de manière considérable ça
comme on le sait on le sait parce que
des scientifiques ont fait des mesures
et on fait des courbes et voilà la
courbe qui a été produite
on appelle la courbe de killing qui
montre l'augmentation du gaz carbonique
au cours de ces 60 dernières années dans
l'atmosphère est alors pour comprendre
le problème que ça pose il faut que des
scientifiques vous explique que cette
augmentation de gaz carbonique est à
l'origine du réchauffement de la planète
et c'est ça à l'origine de
l'augmentation du renforcement des fêtes
de l'effet de serre et que c'est
précisément ça qui est à l'origine du
réchauffement de la planète
d'où la troisième idée c'est que la
réalité se voit pas forcément premier
coup d'oeil
il faut des mesures et des instruments
de mesure alors maintenant venons à mon
expérience personnelle moi je suis
sismologues scénographe je travaille à
l'ifremer je m'intéresse aux séismes
sous marins
parce que la plupart des cdc des
tremblements de terre
en fait au lieu en mer mais depuis une
dizaine d'années je travaille sur la
faille nord anatolienne qui s'étend sur
1500 km de l'est de la turquie jusqu'en
jusqu'en grèce et dans la région
d'istanbul la faille passe en mer et est
donc et dans cette région d'istanbul
peuplé de 15 millions d'habitants
il y a eu beaucoup de séismes au cours
des siècles passés
beaucoup de séismes dévastateurs donc
l'enjeu de nos recherches
c'est d'étudier la faille comprendre
comment ils fonctionnent pour essayer
d'évaluer la probabilité d'occurrence du
prochain séisme
7 heures alors quand on est allés en mer
avec le petit submersible nautile de
l'ifremer on a vu qu'il y avait du
pétrole qui a fait aurait le long de la
faille mais aussi qu'il y avait du gaz
qui s'échappent et par cette faille est
alors quand on a mis nos petits
instruments dont c'était sismomètres on
a vu on a compris et vu que une grande
partie des séismes qui étaient
enregistrés en fait étaient étaient
induits par ce gaz donc une partie des
signes que l'on croyait d'origine
tectonique c'est-à-dire géologique
en fait dès sont liés à la présence de
gaz et ça je pense sans rentrer dans les
détails ça ça change beaucoup beaucoup
pour l'appréciation de l'aléa sismique
de la zone dans la région alors tout ça
semble très simple parce que en euro on
avait des données nouvelles acquises
avec des moyens très sophistiqués de
moyens la mer et donc il était tout à
fait normal naturel que l'on trouve des
résultats nouveau bien évidemment est en
tout cas une vision nouvelle différente
de celle qu'ils avaient acquise
d'autres sismologues qui travaillait
avec des instruments déployés à terre
mais et des données et qu'il y avait des
données beaucoup moins précise et
pourtant pourtant il nous a fallu quatre
ans quatre ans de lutte acharnée pour
publier ses résultats ça veut dire pour
les faire accepter dont seulement par
les gens qui étaient en charge de les
évaluer
mais également par la communauté
scientifique qui travaillaient sur ce
sujet pendant depuis 15 ans et qui était
passé à côté de ce que nous avions vu
depuis que ces résultats sont publiés
donc la réalité est perçu différemment
d'où la quatrième idée c'est que les les
réticences intellectuelle qui bien
réticences intellectuels sont très
difficiles à surmonter y compris dans le
milieu scientifique alors les
connaissances nouvelles finissent pas
l'emporter parce que eux grâce à ce
système de validation vérification
publication des résultats alors
maintenant vous souvenez de la caverne
de platon de l'allégorie de la caverne
de platon donc des hommes sont enchaînés
au fond d'une caverne
ils font n'ont jamais vu le soleil voit
juste un mince filet de lumière qui
parvient jusqu'à 1 sans savoir d'où ça
vient
et ils sont assis au fond de la caverne
et ils font face à la paroisse où il
voit des ombres ils sont projetés par un
feu qui alimentait derrière eux et leur
réalité ce sont ces ombres et un jour 1c
prisonniers tiré de force vers
l'extérieur de la caverne est là à votre
avis qu'est ce qui se passe pour lui et
bien au début ils résistent
irrésistiblement parce qu'ils souffrent
ses yeux lui font terriblement mal il
était ébloui atrocement ébloui par la
lumière du soleil puis au bout d'un
moment il finit par s'habituer
il voit la réalité en dehors la caverne
alors il retourne chercher ses copains
mais quand il revient en fait il reçoit
le pire d accueil c'est l'hostilité
complète l'incompréhension alors même
alors même qu'il annonce qu'il a vu des
fleurs des oiseaux du ciel bleu et
cetera et cetera
parce qu est donc il est rejetée parce
que comme on rejette parce qu'on rejette
tout ce qui vous bousculent tout ce qui
vaut dérange donc c'est la 5ème idée
c'est que c'était pas seulement notre
appréciation de la réalité mais c'est
aussi notre acceptation de la réalité
qui varient qui
évoluent en fonction des connaissances
que l'on à l'acceptation des réalités
donc maintenant je vais vous revenons
aux affaires de climat et je vais vous
raconter une anecdote édifiante qui est
arrivé récemment en 2017
donc il ya un an seulement c'était l'été
gp j'ai eu l'occasion de revoir des amis
de jeunesse
et ce jour là il faisait chaud très très
chaud il savait comme toujours dans ces
cas là on parle du réchauffement
climatique
et là il ya une vieille amie une fille
très diplômés très très très
intelligente très brillante
on se tourne vers moi et qui me dit un
peu pour me mettre dans la connivence
mais oui tu vas pas me dire que tu y
crois toi ces histoires de réchauffement
climatique
tu vas pas me dire que tu crois à
l'influencé de l'homme sur le climat
c'est authentique et là au cours de la
soirée
je me suis rendu compte que dans cette
assemblée de copains sont aujourd'hui
pour la plupart des dirigeants dans
l'industrie eh bien ils pensé comme elle
n'était pas la seule à penser comme ça
bien au contraire
donc ça j'en suis resté interloqué
d'abord mon ami on a posé la question
comme si c'était une question une
affaire de religion mais aussi mais si
je la question c'est mais pourquoi
pourquoi donc
yat-il encore autant de climato
sceptiques chez les gens de mon âge
ou alors des gens qui sont mitigés
killebrew pourquoi pourquoi est il si
difficile de faire admettre que l'homme
est responsable du climat
alors alors qu'il ya un consensus au
sein de la communauté scientifique
donc j'en ai parlé à ma fille 27 ans qui
va animer mais pas par ap ap ap ap ap ap
ap hm
les climatosceptiques c'est tous des
ringards ou alors des complotistes août
et créationnisme ou alors des cyniques
des vendue au lobby industriel
alors moi je m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir
parce que ni mon ami ni les copains là
il enfin dit ne rentre dans aucune de
ces catégories
donc si les lobes si les sceptiques ne
sont pas tous des des lobbyistes est
bien c'est qu'il ya autre chose s'ils ne
se sont pas tous des vendus c'est qu'il
ya autre chose où il ya beaucoup de
raisons qui font qu'on préfère rester
dans la caverne
il ya le confort la préserver son
confort il ya le conformisme sans faille
à la le conservatisme qui fait partie de
la nature humaine
bien sûr il ya la peur de la récession
économique qui est réel il ya
effectivement l'effet de lobby mais il
ya autre chose et c'est là dessus que je
veux en venir c'est autre chose c'est de
nature intellectuelle c'est à dire que
intellectuels n'ont pas compris et cette
nature intellectuelle parce que ces
lignes et à l'enseignement que les gens
mon âge moisissent on s'entend que les
gens mon agent reçu il ya 40 ans il ya
40 ans dans les classes préparatoires il
y avait les sciences noble les maths la
physique c'est-à-dire les sciences dures
et puis il y avait le reste des sciences
molles à l'époque on ne connaissait rien
on ne connaissait rien n'est rien rien
rien de toutes ces interactions entre
des phénomènes complexes comme je vous
ai montré au début on encore on savait
rien donc ça ne s'enseigne pas il ya 40
ans dans l'enseignement dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs s'étaient fondés sur des
certitudes alors qu'aujourd'hui on parle
d'incertitude et de probabilité par
exemple si on vous dit si je vous dis
que l'homme est très probablement à
l'origine du réchauffement climatique
cela a un sens cette phrase et
scientifique
cette assertion et scientifique quand je
dis très probablement c'est un sens
parce que les mots très probablement ont
un sens si on vous dit par exemple que
si vous roulez à 200 km/heure dans une
rue de montagne la nuit avec des
tournants partout vous allez très
probablement finir dans le ravin cela a
un sens car l'accident n'est pas certain
à 100% donc le scientifique qui fait son
travail quand il vous dit très
probablement ça peut être 99% ça peut
être 99 9% mais un scientifique honnête
nous ne peux pas vous dire 100 %
d'où la 6ème année c'est que ma fille a
raison c'est un véritable question de
génération c'est à dire que la nouvelle
génération est mieux armé que la nôtre
mieux armé intellectuellement pour
intégrer la complexité du monde
donc j'arrive à la conclusion c'est que
la séance
ce n'est pas une affaire figée de
concept de dogme figer la science évolue
ce n'est pas une affaire de religion ni
de croyance
nous vivons une véritable révolution des
connaissances pas des concepts mais des
connaissances et ça ça sera du
véritablement par une révolution
scientifique et intellectuelle et comme
dans toute révolution scientifique
cela demande un champ un véritable
changement de paradigme
c'est à dire un une
un changement de notre vision du monde
qui va désormais gouverner qui va
s'imposer dans tout cela dans tous les
domaines de la pensée et donc et donc il
ya espoir il ya espoir c'est à dire que
la jeune génération elle est mieux armé
mieux éduqués pour intégrer ce
changement de paradigme
donc elle saura mieux que la nôtre
observer la nature dans cette auto de sa
complexité croiser les regards et
surtout construire des solutions de
rupture de véritables solutions de
rupture
voilà donc donc donc les jeunes jeunes
générations qui là c'est à vous de
prendre les choses en main c'est
vraiment à vous de prendre les choses en
main voilà et c'est vraiment à vous de
nous sortir de la caverne et maintenant
les moins jeunes qui sont tous là et
bien c'est des temps de nous accorder à
la jeune génération
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]